okay so we got to the message in this
big mess is that the world is messy and
complicated
um I wanted to say the world is messy
and complicated and not just inside mini
Crypt and up but also uh sorry not just
in crypto Mania and up but also within
uh minicrypt so in particular
um
let's consider one-way permutations an
injective one-way functions this
implications are obvious from the
definition one where permutation is a
one-way function such that
um it takes n bit strings to end bit
string it's a permutation over zero and
one to the N for n bit strings and
injective is an injective one-way
function obviously this imply that
um but somehow it's not clear to us
should we put this in minicrypt should
we put it in crypto Mania I don't know
and another primitive that's unclear is
Collision resistant hash function which
I'll Define in a minute in the next
slide just to say something about it
although I'm not sure if we really need
the definition
um but what I wanted to say is that
um
these things imply one-way function it's
not so hard to show but in fact they
don't fit neatly anywhere in this
division two worlds in particular
they are uh you know they don't imply
nor are implied by public key
cryptography
um it's somehow not clearer to put them
and and you know they're much more so
somehow I think them intuition behind
all of these things is the more
structure you have the harder it is but
sometimes more structure goes in
different directions and then it gives
you things that are possibly
incomparable
um okay so I wanted to mention this for
example Collision resistant hash
function is not doesn't fit anywhere
it's also a weird primitive
um I have a definition here of collision
resistant hash function although I
wasn't going to talk about it after this
slide so if you're tired you can like
take a one minute break
but I the reason I wanted to Define it
so what is a collision resistant hash
function
um it's a function such that it's easy
to compute but it's hard to find two
inputs that go to the same output uh
okay and it's
um
what is it called compressing so what I
wanted to emphasize about it it's a
weird primitive because on one hand it's
a little bit public key in the sense
that there is no secret key there are no
secrets everybody knows everything
there's no good guys with the secret
and it distinguishes them from bad guys
in that sense it's kind of similar to
crypto Mania on the other hand it's not
known to be equivalent to anything in
crypto Mania and also in practice we
have like heuristic very fast algorithms
for hash functions which we don't for uh
public encryption foreign
Okay so
this is
sort of what I wanted to say about those
um Two Worlds minicrypt and crypto Mania
um I want to say going up uh up towards
of frustopia or still I don't know these
might be still within cryptomania I
don't know there are many Primitives I
didn't Define that are much stronger and
give you more things
um like fully homomorphic encryption
and attribute-based encryption
functional encryption I'm not going to
Define them and then there's a
distinguishability optification which is
somehow next level
I would say um okay so let me say
something about indistinibility of
discussion it came up before both in my
talking and other talks but not much and
I also will not say too much but I just
feel like I must uh mention it because
it's a it's very related uh to
everything we're talking about so here
is a definition obviously there are
subtleties that I'm skipping in many
versions but basically what is
indistinguishability obfuscation and
this and then distinguishability
obfuscater is an algorithm I call it IO
yes it's an algorithm IO it should be
efficient
um it takes us input a circuit and
outputs another circuit that is
functionally equivalent okay so I O
takes a circuit C and output another
Circuit of polynomially related size
that computes exactly the same function
that's the correctness requirement okay
so it just does the same thing doesn't
change the input output Behavior the
security requirement is that if you have
if you start from two input circuits
that are identical functionality
then their IO they're obfuscated
versions are indistinguishable from each
other
that's the definition roughly speaking
um and
on one hand like where did it come from
why obfuscation it's sort of the
intuition is you hiding whether if I
give you I O of C1 you have no idea if
it's IO C1 or C or iof C2 you don't know
where it came from they look the same so
I obfuscate the difference however it's
seemingly extremely weak
you know I only obfuscate the difference
between identical circuits I don't say
anything about circuits that are not
identical might not obfuscate anything
like my first reaction when I saw this
definition was like it's too weak but
turned out to be super strong it gives
you a ton of things okay that's the
problem if there's any problem with IO
it's not that it's not strong enough
it's like super strong turns out that it
has amazing applications
okay so this is indistinguishability
obfuscation
[Music]
um
yeah any questions
what is equivalent you mean functionally
yes okay good uh equivalent means let's
you could talk about approximations or
whatever but let's say fully equivalent
means exactly the same input output
Behavior
I can try to yeah so that's the first
answer so
yeah so what is the set mode it says the
same size
is it true only for precisely the same
size of servants so maybe uh you but you
can add a circuits to be over related
like if one is a little bigger you can
pad circuits you can add no Ops yes so
the point is that the encryption of a
message reveals something about the size
of them and like how big how long the
message is so this is sort of an
obfuscation of a circuit is like an
encryption of a circuit it has to reveal
something about the size of the circuit
that's what it captures
can we explain to me what your point of
confusion is the the why you you want me
to say it for any two circuits whether
even if they're not of the same size is
that it any two circuits of size up to
end okay the size okay what is
computationally indistinguishable Okay
so
so like real obfuscation which is
obviously good and great and amazing but
we cannot achieve and then they Define
this and this is what I was going to
talk about but basically the initial
idea how people usually motivate it what
is obfuscation I give you a circuit and
I want it to be as if you can run the
circuit and get you give it an input and
you get an output obviously so you can
run it on any input that you wish but I
want you not to learn anything else
about the implementation of the circuit
just the input output Behavior that's
what I want okay that's the intuition of
what I would want so I would want I give
you a circular obfuscate it so that I
don't know maybe there's uh you know for
hiding maybe there's a secret key hidden
and there in the circuit or I don't know
what okay so this is the intuition for
application I want you to know nothing
about what's going on this is called the
vbp obfuscation but it doesn't matter
turns out that this intuition can be
formalized which of course was informal
can be formalized you can formalize the
definition of indistinguishable from uh
or access to an input product with
Oracle versus having the circuit the no
adversary to tell the difference
that is the first thing people usually
say about obfuscation
but then what I said now I could Define
very formally and you would understand
perfectly but then I would say if I took
time but then I would tell you forget it
it's unachievable
so instead this was uh in the paper by
Barakat Al they suggest they in that
paper did many things including proving
what I said now is impossible but they
also suggested a relaxed notion they
viewed it as a relaxed notion where I'm
not really hiding what the circuit does
you know I'm not hiding it truly but I'm
just hiding how I implemented it for
example for example maybe I could
Implement identical functionality in two
circuits C1 and C2 one of them
implemented because it knows this Secret
sk1
like I don't know maybe I have a circuit
if I know the social security number of
any of you I can do something so I have
one circuit that uses your social
security number and another circuit that
uses my social security number or
something like that I don't want to
reveal it in the clear so people don't
see how I implemented it
I think
um I think your question is Justified in
the sense that this I've seen by now
this definition many times but the first
100 times I saw this definition to me it
doesn't really
sound like strong enough obfuscation I'm
just hiding two circuits that are
identical then you can tell where it
came from identical functionality it
literally fully input out the behaviors
let's say but yet when you see the
applications and the proofs of How It's
applied you understand why it's so
strong so it turns out to be an
amazingly strong primitive okay but the
definition just to be clear and the
definition an obfuscater takes a circuit
and outputs another circuit uh or maybe
it will become even more clear in a
minute when I uh say something about it
it will become clear for example here is
a great obfuscater except it's not
efficient take the lexicographically
first circuit that computes this
function this satisfies everything
beautifully except for efficiency
uh right because you give me a circuit
I'll find the first
bookstoreographically first circuit that
does the exact same thing and the truth
table I'll give you the truth table
that's another is there are issues with
what I'm saying about deficiency but if
we ignore them in terms of functionality
that would satisfy it so I want to do it
efficiently
um
okay uh and it's a deterministic circuit
or a deterministic function it doesn't
have to be deterministic no
preferably randomized
it can't be deterministic
um
realistic you could apply it to yourself
like the adversary could apply it to
somehow yeah or something I think
there's equivalent to people
unsatisfied I don't know if it's
equivalent but yeah
yeah exactly because you could add yeah
you could hard code like the canonical
circuit for something that accepts test
it yeah
I agree with what you said until the
last sentence which I didn't understand
like if you had a deterministic one like
then there's some fixed uh canonical
thing that anytime you put an
unsatisfiable like a circuit in there
that's the exact one thing
good good good I agree yeah somebody
else there raise your hand but I forgot
the minimal thing sounds like search
mcsd so can you reduce this
weird because mcsp would break one-way
functions good so let me talk about it
in a minute I don't exactly exactly know
how to answer it but it's very related
to something I have in a couple of
slides and then we will have a lively
discussion if I don't answer it well
okay
um good so it turns out that IO enables
many many many new cryptographic
applications which I'm not gonna get
into because Mike I already gave you
enough Primitives my point is more to
talk about complexity assumptions and
what implies what uh but turns out that
you can do a ton of things uh with IO
this is not quite right but IO plus
one-way functions you could do a ton of
things
okay and it has very interesting
complexity and World implications which
is related to what you asked
which I will show
um so one good question is does IO exist
and the answer is well it definitely
exists if P equals to NP easily this is
what I said before right this is a bit
weird because usually cryptographic
Primitives they don't exist if P equals
to NP like I don't know encryption or
whatever I O in fact does exist if P
equals to NP
just to what I said before is in fact
efficient if we are in algorithmica but
the question is can we build IO you know
if we're not in algorithmica like can we
prove that one-way function in plyo can
we prove that I don't know what
fullyomorphic encryption imply or what
can we prove implies I owe
um so the first candidate construction
um
wasn't so the paper that suggested this
notion was in 2001 and the first
candidate construction was much much
later in 2013. let me see if I can say
all the authors uh
Garg Gentry rykova sahayan Waters
I think I'm not very nice
what
very nice Oh I thought I'm missing
someone good okay this was trivia for
myself I don't have chocolate for you so
I do trivia for myself
uh anyway so they've suggested some
candidate construction which was a big
breakthrough but there was no satisfying
assumption that can prove there was
nothing there since then there was lots
and lots of progress towards uh standard
assumption so basically the point is we
don't know if IO exists we have proof so
before we didn't even have a proof of
like if this weird looking but
reasonable assumption holds then I O
exist even that we didn't have now we do
have it
um so there's a bunch of papers uh
they have some assumptions that imply
the combination of a bunch this is an
example of one paper this one is from
uh Jane Lin and sahai okay I'm gonna
stop trying to say names because
um
anyway
um they they uh prove that you can build
it assuming some combination of four
assumptions these four assumptions are
not quite standard uh they all have some
special version of something okay first
of all also everything is
um sub-exponential but anyway this I
ignored throughout my talk so I'll
ignore now as well
um
one of the assumptions relates to
um minicrypt because it has to do with
prg and nc0 which we do have but like
with special properties of expansion
um
sxdhsm pairing assumption I won't focus
on that so now we are making a lot of
progress towards proving that it exists
but it's not so clear yet what I wanted
to say I wanted to say a few words on
the implications of IO to
impelliato's world
okay
um
good so
um
I somehow picked things that relate to
what IO does to employers world because
that was the theme
um
of my talk okay so I'll highlight three
results basically it eliminates a lot of
Worlds
um one is it shows that if you have IO
then private key encryption implies pke
I could say the i o plus one-way
function implies public key encryption I
could say it like this
um but basically so a lot of these
proofs not all of them but a lot of
statements like that are sort of not
hard not too hard to prove or understand
intuitively if I really had a vbb but
they are harder to prove with IO but
people manage to prove it so the
intuition for example for private key
encryption implies public key encryption
I could publish the encryption algorithm
with the secret key embedded in it in an
obfuscated way that's a very high level
intuition and you need to work hard to
make it work with IO but
okay so
um this means if I all exist there is no
mini [ __ ] we eliminated minicrypt
because when we function plus IO uh
gives you crypto menu uh good
then another paper uh eliminates also
the previous two worlds the heuristic
and pestilent uh they show that in fact
if you assume IO then uh hardness on
average of NP implies one-way functions
that's a clean way to say it not quite
accurate there's an
some i o issues Rafael claims IO I oh
sorry sorry here IO is infinitely open
sorry I'm sorry this IO BPP is
infinitely off in BPP
um anyway Raphael claims this is the
right definition anyway so okay
um
good so so therefore the limit it can
take you directly from algorithm if IO
exists then it takes you from
algorithmica to officeopia
uh okay so it has a lot of power uh if
you assume it but this assumption is
very strong and we don't know how to
reduce it to better assumptions for now
and separately on the line remember from
one-way function to uh one way
permutation you can in fact
show that one-way function does imply
one-way permutations if you assume dial
okay so this I just wanted to mention
some things that eliminate uh connection
that eliminate
um uh barriers that we know otherwise
yesterday was a question about whether
there are Chandra reconstructions of
reductions to show MP completeness of
mktp and so on
you can get one because of combining
this with the uh what we showed in the
previous talk right because we said that
if you can like yeah what's the
equivalent to showing and the completed
so very certain things that there was
exactly a picture of what will happen if
you eliminate heuristica in passive Land
There is a reduction
completes using a non-blackbox way
because it
because it relates on the security of IO
this won't work for every Oracle that
breaks the uh mktp but if you have a
fundamental or calibration PDP then you
have a way of solving set
and we have cancer there is candidate
instructions basically for the reduction
that we cannot break unless we break the
ion
still requires a lot more
research and work both for attacks or
Construction
solid but super interesting
but basically we should believe that
these things are empty complete and
unless you can break down here
but some people believe you can break IO
it's not so ridiculous
like mcsps can be completed this none
Black Box way right because uh the
statement
uh
he uh sorry
mcspice but but you don't have a you
still don't have a reduction on
candidates right this gives your
reduction candidates
is
right this gives you a reduction
the reduction is we know how to like uh
our paper shows introduction how to
break
and when we functions using akdp then
you have the reduction from prg to
um
and then you have to just uh do this
obfuscation
black
actually the reduction curiosity is
Black Box it says it does if there is
these two rely on the fact that Oracle
is the size about that but the reduction
actually is black focus is kind of
curious because all of these things are
black books but having any reduction is
amazing right the whole black boxness is
more of a tool I mean it's good
for positive results it's okay if it's
not black box
but there may be a mission like I guess
you could use your paper to break
one-way functions
so you're saying
okay
isn't there something more direct that
you can do if you have IO I mean no how
do you break how do you break sat using
mttp Oracle you you you you take uh you
take the circuit the CNF formula you
obfuscate it together with maybe like a
message or some some random string of
some form if the circuit is
unsatisfiable this guy never outputs the
uh it is the equivalent to the zero
circuit right uh and I asked the mcspr
to give me the smallest circuit see that
the zero circuit or it's it's it's it's
so big it must be something more yeah
I know I know right
super interesting
I encourage
when I give this obstetric program to
you uh I know that either it has a very
small circuit that there's a very small
circle that computes it or there isn't
right I mean it's now I want
uh if you solve it then you break the i
o
um
or you break the
before you're so upset this is what I
want to feel no but you cannot
distinguish between something you might
not be able to distinguish between the
formulas that have one satisfying
assignment
and a unsatisfiable
you can take this offline Maybe
you think online but uh yeah
okay
um so
yeah your observation break right that
was my observation in the break that's
what you asked me right okay
okay so
I think let me see I think that's all I
wanted to say about these worlds
um what I want to do so you know when I
prepared the talk I thought up to now
there's not that much of things that I
really want to do research on but this
discussion has changed my mind there's
many things I want to do research on
related to everything I just said which
is awesome uh now I wanted to say some
general directions of things I want to
do research on that are somewhat related
to this uh because like this boot camp
is like oh let's have some common
language so we can all do research
together during this semester
um okay so that's what I'll do and I'll
definitely end on time because I can
stop at any point but we'll see
um Okay so
so this uh
the topic I want to discuss is circuit
complexity of cryptographic Primitives
so now looking a little more zooming in
into not just crypto main not just
polynomial time
um
okay the high level question is what is
the parallel complexity of cryptographic
Primitives I want to unmotivate it more
and say what I'm talking about and where
it's coming from Etc
um so there is this uh line of work that
started with um uh Apple by Machine Levi
it's about crypto and nc0 where they
basically show how to compile various
cryptographic primitive you give me a
cryptographic primitive that is let's
say in nc1 and I compile it to the
existence of the same primitive in nc0
okay
um
nc0 our constant the constant depth
circuits
um with ends and ORS and bounded Fannin
and nc1 is Log and depth circuits so we
know all of the crypto Primitives in nc1
exist from standard assumptions
factoring Etc so not based on their work
they could achieve it in nc0 I'm not
elaborating because I'm not going to
focus on this I just wanted to mention
it and this works for many cryptographic
Primitives that I listed there one way
function P or g equals the hash function
all the things I listed there uh in the
break I don't know if it was below the
Raphael I think it was Raphael who just
had to leave but Raphael was saying that
or maybe it was vinod anyway that really
the truth is all of these things
definitely exist in nc0 you don't need
to assume nc1 but we just haven't proved
it yet so do you stand by it yes good
okay uh but but that's like some gut
feeling this is like like an actual
theorem however this theorem does not
that there they do it using uh
randomized encodings it's very beautiful
line of work there are many Works in
that line but it doesn't apply to
pseudorandom functions so I'll Define in
a minute or what these things are
um but it doesn't apply to pseudorandom
functions like you cannot do you cannot
use it to get to the random functions
then c0 this is obviously not surprising
at all because you cannot have
pseudorandom functions of nc0 everything
I'm saying now is an overview and I'm
going to say it again more detailed in
the next slide so with more
justification
I open
no
yeah
I owe that gets input a description of a
circle and Company
yeah yeah
if you mean if the option scatter itself
was an nc1 yeah yes how would you get it
in NC series just applied around the
best including work okay
yeah I guess the intuition is let me
think about it the intuition is what it
needs the secret and fresh Randomness so
I guess it makes sense it works for
Primitives where each application
has some Randomness that this is just
intuition it's not anything has some
Randomness that is uh not given as part
of the output a secret and it's fresh
each time whereas props exactly don't
have a prfs which I'll Define in a
minute you can think of the secret key
as random it is random but it's secret
but I thought with IO you were supposed
to output something that was actually
functionally equivalent and
the uh you know there's lots of stuff in
MC1 that is not functionally equivalent
to something at NCC road so you can't
compile all the way down oh I think he's
asking for this I owe it so in the
description of the office case the
obfuscater program itself
it's the complexity not of the input
programs
getting nc1 circuits but whether
obfuscater runs or whether the office
yeah right it's a it's the complexity of
the office together that's the current
of the schedule running and see what
[Music]
I mean yeah
what's really easy compiling down to nc0
I mean in the in the
the cryptography in NC zero paper I mean
taking the you mean the randomizing
coding method
yeah easy in the complexity size yeah
um
this is our conditioner on the fact that
the crypto so you have and then you do
something so it should be a white very
white box so the theorem of their
theorem is if there exists let's say
one-way function in nc1 then there
exists a one-way function in nc0 the
conjecture of vinod is if there exists a
one-way function then there exists a
one-way function and then c0
foreign
function and P right
let's be known as a conjecture okay
um so this is just some background I'm
going to try to send things oh yeah good
I'm gonna say and now I'm going to
motivate exactly what the questions are
and what I think might be interesting to
work on
um so I didn't have time to write the
definitions and therefore I wrote them
here
um I want to Define what P or D and prfs
are okay pure G is a pseudorandom
generator maybe you all know but if
somebody doesn't know like really feel
free to ask more questions so uh this is
the definition of a prg
um it's a deterministic function that
takes let's say any n Bits to let's say
it's length doubling and bits to two n
Bits And I want the output of G on a
uniform distribution to be
indistinguishable computationally
indistinguishable uh from truly random
okay that's prg it takes short string
gives long string takes a short random
string gives a long
just a random looking string a prf is a
function I don't know how easy it is to
read but let me try to explain it a prf
is a set of functions FK let's say from
n Bits to n Bits or if you like Boolean
functions it can be Boolean doesn't
matter
um
yeah I know some people here like
Boolean functions let me make it Boolean
doesn't matter
um it's a family of functions uh where
the key is of length and bits and the
point is that what is indistinguishable
the distribution that are in
distinguishes for any polynomial time
distinguisher a that has Oracle axis to
F so it can submit inputs and get
outputs adaptively it's an algorithm in
any order it wants submit input and gets
output and at the end wants to determine
whether F was chosen uniformly at random
from this family with some key of length
n or F was chosen uniformly at random
from the set of all possible functions
that where truly random function or not
okay so you somehow I think intuitively
you can think of a prf a prg like a
pseudorandom string and a prf like an
exponentially long in a prg the output
is of polynomial size and it looks
random in a prf you can think of the
truth table as exponentially long
pseudor random uh
you know truth table and the adversary
can access any row that he wants
um
I wanted to suggest the definition of
weak prf a weak prf
is similar to a prf except there's no
adversary that can it's it's uh like
random examples rather than a query
access to the Oracle the adversary
cannot ask inputs and get output but
instead in a weak prf uh a gets a gets
random examples
um
so the only difference in Weak prf uh is
that a doesn't get to choose uh
to choose the examples it gets uniformly
random yeah
FK of let's say f x q F K of xq it gets
uniformly random example it's like
membership query in in learning it's
like membership query and prf versus
random examples and weak PRS and still
needs to distinguish whether it was
truly random function or was chosen from
this set okay
say that again
so good they all imply each other and
they're all equivalent to each other
into one-way Function One Way function
if and only if P or G if and only if we
prf if and only if prf imply in the
sense that if you have give me this I
can use it to construct a different one
of that
um good and
um let me say let me think
uh where to say it
okay I wanted to say something but see I
don't have it in the slide something
about there's some relation to learning
here very roughly speaking weak prf is
sort of if you have a weak prf in the
class then that class is not learnable
from random examples roughly speaking uh
you need to look at the parameters but
there's a connection to learning
here like it's a very strong connection
to learning
um
yeah definitely if the class has a weak
prf then it's not learnable and the
converse might be sort of true like you
need to be more careful but there's a
connection uh okay so
what I wanted to say
is the following uh when we function
from ofp or different only if prf if and
only if weak prf they're all the same in
terms of complexity in minicrypt but I
wanted to say
um
oh this like the slide came all at once
and not one by one but I wanted to say
something about it
um more slowly
in some sense they're all equivalent but
really the gut feeling they're not all
the same okay they're different in some
way so I will say why they're different
in an intuitive way and in a formal way
intuitively uh for example prg implies
One Way function is trivial
okay one-way function in pi prg is
highly highly highly non-trivial okay
that's the Hill Construction Raphael was
referring to it as very complicated in
the stock highly non-trivial when you
teach crypto you sort of say a class
intro to crypto you sort of say these
things but you never I never prove
one-way function imply prg you know I
can prove maybe one way permutation
imply hardcore bid imply prg with gold
Rec 11 but that's one way permutation so
I just want to say somehow some of these
directions are harder to prove than
others
um that's one idea the other idea the
other point is that the parallel circum
complexity of these construction is very
very different uh what is parallel
circuit complexity just uh to remind you
it's not very important uh each one of
these but generally we look at circuits
NC circuits have ends in R's
um of bounded fannine AC have unbalted
Shannon
um zero means the depth is constant one
means the depth is logarithmic
and sees any polylog depth
um okay and ac02 is
for example is
um constant depth unbounded fan in
circuits which also allow mod 2 that's
the two allow parity Gates okay so
there's some
uh things that we know I wanted to say
that prg and nc0 from standard
assumption is known like I said before
whereas prf for example in nc0 it's not
that it's not known but it's easily
cannot
B you can prove that there is no pure
reference zero or even an ac0 and this
follows from this is related to the
connection to learning it follows from
the fact that uh from learning results
uh and in fact they can't even be an ac0
mod 2. okay based on the raspberry
fruitish natural proof idea and that was
uh discussed I think in some length in
somebody's talk I've forgotten who's
yes
okay okay I'm talking about full
security I guess I I here I didn't write
I just wrote uh indistinguishable good
I'm talking about yeah I'm not talking
about quasi polynomial security but uh
let's say exponential some exponential
okay uh
good so there's some possibility results
that immediately try this
um
now the learning thing applies equally
to the prf and to weak prf it's the same
uh but the natural proof Paradigm
doesn't apply to weak prf because
somehow they're random examples don't
suffice so one question to ask is
whether weak trfs can be in uh some
lower complexity class than we know now
and I need to say in which complexity
class we know it now which I think I
have an aside uh good so
so one thing I want to ask is about
um
what is the best parallel complexity we
can find for uh weak prf Weak prf by the
way in addition to I just defined it and
I said they're all equivalent but weak
prf is also somehow
um
qualitatively stronger than prg and
qualitatively weaker than prfs in some
intuitive way and they suffice to many
of the applications that we have for
prfs for example for efficiency Etc yeah
for which cases are you talking about
the week here I've been compatible
uh
pre-processing versus not reprocessing
like I think that's the same so when you
sample one from the family
and I think so your sample so you're
asking about the security game
I think uh in the standard definition
you're allowed polynomial time sampling
but in both of them I have in both BFF
and weak prf I have a adversary a that
runs in polynomial time
he's talking about key generation yeah
oh so so in any case the kid generation
is chosen first at once and then the
adversary has consistent access to the
same FK
so the tc0 candidate
is not in cases zero as a function of
the key as well or just can't see what
you're asking you're asking about
whether the sampling could be in tc0 I
was talking about the evaluation but I
think the sampling is also
um
there this you're talking about this
line the orango that's like some ddh
like exponentiation
um
blog
my I was focusing on the evaluation of
the Computing f of x yeah so so
evaluation just means as it is on this
live just means that every
family is considerable
easy to compute which I didn't even
write here the F needs to be easy I only
talked about security and this this
exactly is what I'm talking about yeah
so we know how to compute it from some
specific assumptions like ddh and some
others but we don't know how to compute
it in less than nc1 from any generic way
in a generic way and this is sort of
what I wanted
um
to talk about so
I also want to say yeah this this is
what I wanted to talk about
um I want to say this is something I
talked about with Marshall and I think I
also talked about it with Igor but that
was a hundred years ago I talked about
iron Marshall recently for any of you
Marshall and Igor or anybody else want
to work on it it's very interesting to
me here is a more concrete question so
far I was just talking a little bit
generically about it's interesting to
understand circuit complexity of
Primitives
and they're not all the same but now
here is a concrete question uh let's
talk about the construction of prf from
generic assumptions for example the
construction of prf from prg
um okay so we know that PR G implies prf
uh in the construction we know is by ggm
from the 80s okay it's a beautiful
construction and it looks I will not
show the construction but I'll just say
uh
it involves a binary tree of each each
node is an application of G of the prg
Okay g is length doubling it so to
compute you start with the key and to
compute FK of X you need to go down the
tree according to x the first bit of X
the second bit of X the third bit of X
Etc so the ggm construction and then
they prove that the resulting thing is
the one-way uh sorry so it's a random
function assuming the G is a pseudonym
generator this construction is of linear
depth you apply linearly many times G
linearly many times n times where n is
the length of the input one after the
other and since then we don't have any
this was like the first I think and we
don't have any better construction that
is less than we don't have any like I
don't know polylog depth construction
from prg we do have constructions from
like ddh from concrete number theoretic
assumptions but not from generic ones
um
they build a weak prf
um
yes in ac0
mod 2 uh first of all it's a candidate
um
yeah there wasn't a proof it's a
candidate and it's definitely not from
prg or from one-way function it's
definitely not from generic assumption
so one question is could we build prf
from
prg in a in a depth that is less than
linear now in our rheingold which was
also a long time ago they did have a
cons they did have a generic
construction of prf from weak prf of log
depth so therefore
it's all it suffices for us to view can
we build weak prf from prg in log
polylog depth in NC okay
um that's the first question which I
think is very interesting
but in general can we build prf from
other generic Primitives in a in a
low depth like let's say from trapdo
permutation again based on the orangold
you could do that if you had a trapdoor
permutation uh where both the sampling
and the inverting are in NC so these are
questions that we don't know and I also
wanted to mention one last question
that's sort of unrelated to certain
complexity depth but just to number of
applications this ggm prf from PRD as I
said is still the best one we know even
though it's very like linear and
everything it's also linearly many times
we call G can we build prf from prg with
fewer calls to G can we call it with a
single call to G like my feeling is oh
obviously not
this this we talked about Igor like a
hundred years ago but we didn't manage
to
uh refute it like I don't know how to
prove that you can't
but is there any construction
forget about the job yeah so first of
all it's a regular the ggm is strong prf
that also implies a weak prf
it's better
from prg you're saying any yeah
strong period versus Swiftor I think not
but I may be wrong there's nothing like
direct from here yeah there's
construction from number theoretic
assumptions yeah you sure of this I also
think so but I don't know
it's a full-blown prf
yeah is the better there's definitely
not well not definitely but I couldn't
find any that is
you know in a logarithmic depth but I
don't know if any constructions of weak
prf
from prg that are not already
don't even have it yeah I don't think so
but if you don't care about the depth
then like why not just go to prf all the
way
um so if somebody knows a better answer
I don't think there are but if somebody
wants to correct me I'll be happy
ah yeah good you would be ggm good I
guess there's some little uh you're
right there's
um you could potentially have n over uh
and minus login maybe and then you
wouldn't be ggm and I bet you could do
that artificial in actually now that I
think about it good yeah that's that's a
good answer because of the
no orangold result which I don't see now
yeah here now our angle has a log depth
construction of prf and with prf
well the timing is perfect I thought I
will be an hour early what you also
increased the airity of the DGM tree
yeah
there are things about uh expansion and
parameters which I obviously was very
uh sweeping under the rug but maybe
actually you could do something useful
with them for weak prf
more than like somehow they're things
that are easier to do with weak prf than
strong prfs
parama they're wise I know it's vague
but yeah we should talk about it
um good so that's it for that and then I
both ran out of time of making slides
but I have many more things that are
super interesting so I put like a one
line of each and now I see it's perfect
for the timing so I want to say them
okay
um
right
and check the time perfect good uh so
this is now I have a bunch of slides
with zero details but just some similar
to roles talking the first day when he
said like you're a 10 problem I have
like only two or three I don't remember
how many uh but without much detail I
won't talk much but I just want to say
something
um
so one question was already brought up
in previous talks uh several times uh
which is meta complexity above minicrypt
right can we bring Rafael and Yani to
higher worlds uh and in particular
um this we had this discussion now in
the in the break about
um you know maybe you could just prove
that
komogorov complexity one of their
specific problems or something like that
implies public encryption it wouldn't
um contradict things I said before
because it's not black box
but maybe there's another like
this this I don't have anything deeper
to say about this other than obviously
it's an interesting problem to try to
characterize other functionalities
uh right and we know is this did I
understand correctly in the break you
came up with this exact problem right so
yeah so we both came with it
independently so it's obviously
interesting problem
is that about this
is
it the barrier if you come up with a
construction that is relativizing
I mean it's just a complexity based
construction
yeah I don't think it will be I I mean
it's a barrier that it's really really
really hard to the barrier is that it's
equivalent to one way function and it's
really really hard to construct pke for
one-way function
but I don't think there's a formal
barrier
um but even if you don't use those
things that are equivalent to one-way
functions some other meta complexity
problems you know what nutmega some any
problem that is equivalent to PK not
meta not complexity anything would be
great I think
but meta complexity would be amazing
um
that's one the other one I wanted to say
I cannot not mention
Quantum so you know if we stick a cue in
front of everything what do we get
um
fish and in fact it's very interesting I
didn't have time to draw a nice picture
uh also I'm not a big expert but there
are experts here for this I wanted to
say that now New Dawn New Era there's
quantum computers uh you all know that a
bunch of the specific assumptions we use
all the ones that are used currently in
practice are broken with a quantum
computer uh because of shorts factoring
algorithm factoring in the street log
are broken lattices we don't know how to
break
um okay so let's think about a Quantum
landscape first of all I want to say in
the quantum landscape you have to be
careful what you're talking about who is
quantum the good guys
also or the good guys the classic but
the adversaries are bad but in all cases
it's interesting to think about it and I
just want to say
it really really changes all my
intuition at least it's totally totally
and totally
off everything is very different and
they have all the things that we all
used to they're totally not true what
whether you're just talking about post
quantum which is what people use when
the good guys are classic and the bad
guys are quantum or you use fully
Quantum or even the good guys at Quantum
so I just wanted to say some examples a
key agreement
can be done unconditionally uh that's a
big deal because like we can this is
like easily impossible in the classical
World one-way function is not implied by
Primitives like OT which I think of a
super strong primitive that implies
everything doesn't imply when we
function not even classical one-way
function in the quantum World okay
signature schemes and by public
encryption and the classic Word
signature schemes are like one-way
function in private key encryption
um
okay they can have hardness that comes
from the quantum without
uh breaking the P versus NP barriers so
I don't want to say much about it
because I don't know much although I
encourage discussion because other
people can answer better than me but the
worlds are very different there and I
think it's very interesting uh to map so
there are some candidates there are a
bunch of papers coming out all the time
very recently uh on this trying to
suggest like there was this EFI paired
trying to suggest a new Central Hub that
will be equivalent to everything or will
imply a lot of things
um good
that was another one I will encourage
comments after a discussion or even now
uh I don't know enough about this but
I'm super interested I would be happy to
work on it
um I've been educated a bit by both
Colombia and Berkeley amazing Quantum
students who all were at Columbia last
term and my colleague Henry U.N
um okay
but not educated enough so we need to be
educated more
um okay
um and there are many more so there's uh
even more things uh
that are cool and amazing and
interesting maybe I'll say one sentence
about each of them so I didn't talk at
all about fine-grained cryptography what
is fine-grained cryptography it's where
uh it's not the you know sometimes you
can't do something like for example this
thing that I drew here before in the key
agreement you cannot do key agreement
with respect to a random Oracle right
that's the employee attributed old old
result even there you could still dare
do key agreement uh if you assume that
the adversary is just a little bit more
limited than the good guys right like if
the adversary can uh you could the
adversary cannot run in time more than
uh cannot run in time in quadratic time
so the good guys can run in linear time
and any adversary in quadratic time
cannot break it so fine-grade
cryptography is in this setup where uh
you just in the adversary is just
uh is not arbitrary polynomial but you
limit them and there's a lot of
interesting things going on there crypto
and pfnp are planned to do a many slides
on it which I didn't get to but I see I
don't have any time uh but that's super
interesting connections there are tfnp's
um
you know total search fund not just the
total search function complexity there's
a lot of there's some potential I view
it there's some potential for more
hardness uh results from there and
there's a lot of work there I wanted to
mention unclone polymers because I'm
talking about weird things like Quantum
this is something even more weird uh
this is a work of mine with many people
uh let me see with Radha Alma tomorrow
that's Anna's name she's the lab person
bile breitman and Johnny
Johnny I forgot his last name okay sorry
anyway uh we use biology in order to
achieve uh we use uncleanable you know
in Quantum part of the reason I didn't
talk at all about Quantum why is it all
so weird
uh is because of this you know you
cannot unclone ability so an uncleanable
polymers you also have it but it's a
little bit different it gives you new
things that you cannot get with quantum
um this is just a laundry list of things
I would have discussed if I had time
but I didn't so I just wanna
uh it's unbelievable my timing great uh
thank you it's your discussions were
perfect uh
these are my goals for the semester and
yeah uh thank you
but I would love to work with any of you
on all of these things or any of these
things so we have time for questions
yeah
thanks for doing everything
questions comments
the quantum page yeah is there something
wrong to correct me or suggest more
things I may be wrong
yes good so what is quantum meta
complexity
for the state audience oh like mcsp
style thing for Quantum I see I see and
what results are known about it you see
I know nothing about it that sounds
super interesting so what is known about
it
and is it is it like totally
um
is the
is it implied is cryptography is quantum
crypto cryptography any of these
Primitives imply immediately that it's
hard like in the classical sense
yes
good so that's very similar to the
classical analog
yeah
that sounds amazing that's like taking
uh yanyan Rafael Quantum yeah
yeah
that's great I love it
yes you mentioned this like these
barriers for Black Box production in
reminding of the Black Box uh the Black
Ops barrier for worcestry kids reaction
with CMT which Surety bypasses
is
yeah I don't know what your question is
but this reminded me an answer to a
question that was asked before the break
which which is related to this uh right
Rahul you asked for an example of
something that is none black box and
relativizing and this the the switches
result is Man black box but relative ice
no that's exactly what I asked because
it was there any animal this question
crypto which could apply matter so in
the break but suddenly Raphael said that
um but I don't know what it means
honestly in terms of
barriers or implications
of a medical complexity does similar
Black Box literalization
yeah I don't know so I'll give you your
friends today you're saying if there's
negative results that rules sound Black
Box Productions
it doesn't rule out from literacy
abductions potentially that's a space
for medical care I mean because there's
not a ton of such results but there are
some
um
and in fact I think all of those uh
weird Oracle separations with the the
relate to the obfuscation with
oracleated separations
I don't know if they rule out
relativizing
so I'm just the reason I'm thinking is I
don't know if there are many such
examples
but at least it's not an empty set
given the fact that previous discussion
by Rafael so is there a reason to
believe
um believe that it isn't doesn't um the
fact that you say that Quantum here uh
actually that cryptography doesn't work
under the quantum it doesn't really give
you a new result the fire about complex
wait it's not that cryptography doesn't
work is that the implications don't work
like you could Define there is
cryptography in fact the cryptography
works amazingly you can do key agreement
with zero assumptions so it's just
what's easy and what's hard and under
what assumptions changes
but you are asking whether that implies
something for komogorov complexity in a
Quantum world is that what you're asking
I don't know the answer to that but it's
related to our discussion maybe you have
something better you can say I don't
know
yes yes we will uh among all of us
I guess just something important to keep
in mind with this question is that like
implicitly when you when like some these
statements
they've implicitly changed the
definitions of some of the objects
and the definition has changed in the
sense that the
allows you to communicate a Quantum
State when executing the oblivious
transfer protocol which means somehow
that like your messages are no longer
classical functions
I agree with that but that's the meaning
of the letter Q right yeah
mean various different things you could
ask for a classical on my phone because
it's computable by a that whose
efficiency is only gone in in hdb right
that's another thing
right so that that's also the reason why
OT in a Quantic world doesn't imply one
with functions right maybe what do you
exactly because it comes from the
quantum yes you could also ask about
classical OT like like a classical OT
function algorithms Computing the
functions are allowed to be Quantum and
now it's still that would imply like a
Quantum computable one-way function
probably but yeah so you're saying
there's like many details let's hear
what the definitions of the Primitive
should be yeah
um so is there anything strange
I mean then the pictures just before
just the adversar is a Quantum and all
the good guys are not Quantum
um well then then you end up having to
make arguments about sort of the
commodograph complexity and other things
difficult for quantum computers being
hard for quantum computers but it seems
likely that you get sort of like you get
the same one-way functions and you argue
that those one-way functions are post
Quantum but uh yeah exactly this this
setting is usually referred to as post
Quantum to differentiate from all these
other settings
and this is what now like in Practical
crypto like they're trying to build
because all the Practical crypto is
broken but they're trying to build new
crypto but it's all supposed to be
classical but secure against
so the so lattices are considered post
Quantum but I don't deeply understand
why Beyond we don't know how to break it
like maybe somebody will break it later
I don't know
there's a reduction that at least one
that is a Quantum reduction
there are like classical reduction that
doesn't work in Quantum work like even
if in first one tomorrow uh yeah like if
uh let's say rewinding I guess it's
possibility
there are some yeah I think there's like
a paper in crypto this year by
uh
uh yeah and uh the shows like uh well a
classical reductions you have to satisfy
some kind of properties to make it like
also work
yeah yeah when you if the rewind link is
exactly right yeah because yeah good
and where you have the the reductions
were in classical where you run an
algorithm and if you don't like the
result you try again or you sample it
many times but in Quantum you cannot do
it
yeah there's many papers about it but
they're all super recent so I think a
lot is still open and unclear and
interesting
so can I ask the questions
well in the sense is there a Quantum
insecure one-way function but uh but uh
you know uh
but from a Quantum it's a good one we
function you cannot construct a family
Secure Public induction and when you say
Quantum is secure let me just ask you
mean post Quantum meaning
all of us are classical adversaries yeah
that's of course Quantum let's agree to
call it first Quantum I don't know the
answer
somebody else you're asking whether the
black box and possibility results
because it's relative Rising yeah
you're easy to convince
any other
performance questions
um it's hard for me to answer this on
one hand there are ad hoc proofs for
each pair of Primitives but on the other
hand they all follow a small number of
types they're not like all radically
different like what you need to do the
framework is the same or it's not the
same there's a few Frameworks but not
that many there's four or five I don't
know how many few but then you have to
instantiate it and it's not always easy
like you need to build the Oracle for
the Primitive in mind and it's not
always
easy so I don't know if there's
something more I don't know if there's a
meta theorem that's what you're asking
any primitive that satisfies the
following conditions one two three does
not imply in a black box way any
primitive that satisfy conditions four
five six that actually now that I said
it in these words it sounds greatly
familiar
but I don't know if there are papers
like this is exactly a meta theorem
that's what you ask
ing it sounds to be like it's ring some
though but I don't know
question
I understood it correctly right yeah
something like this should be able to
separate one-way functions from K Bremen
but should not be able to separate
one-way functions from brgs right yeah
but you will have what properties you
want I mean you can trivially make it
work if you're uh adapt the properties
to what you want but the question is is
there something interesting General I
don't know
well I've been avoiding working on Black
Box separations because they're so I
worked a lot on them in the past and
they're so hard and tedious to write and
think and not make a mistake
uh but you get something in return so
it's interesting like I would prefer to
have reductions and separations but the
truth is that they're separated you've
got to separate
okay
[Music]